how's it going me my and welcome to
jazzpunk [ __ ]
this game is supposed to be funny I like
funny let's [ __ ] it let's play it
alright see what this game is all about
goddamn it when will you stop inviting
me to these [ __ ] groups man you bros
broke my scene by the way I hope you're
a guy in there for sure real hard to
keep up yeah I'm a little sick by the
way so pardon my constant sniffing all
right whoa whoa whoa whoa so we came out
of how did our head fit in there okay
don't ask questions I guess is that kind
of game all right
don't Darlington Carter Fairfax
important no we don't want to go there
we want to go the door that sup hey lady
don't [ __ ] tell me what to do okay
fine
huh Shay read readers soak play BOTS
that's my jam that's my jam
hey good do you want my job and your
face see you now
we have like a jam throw a concert on
Friday okay hey I will say we much
business to discuss the [ __ ] are you
drinking are you drinking that just to
match your tie that's [ __ ] hipster
man but I'm not gonna sit down I'm not
gonna do that
you're not gonna stop staring at me will
you okay
finally we need you to infiltrate the
Soviet consulate I said I've taken some
of our important technology and it's
imperative we get back on the right
hands my language the wine cellar really
[Laughter]
start a mission in three sure what I'm
so [ __ ] high hyped let's do this [ __ ]
how does it still invite me I'm offline
I don't what to join your [ __ ] groups
oh god I'm sorry but god damn infiltrate
the Soviet consul constantly what
happens if we go here I'm sorry I always
have to do that hey man yeah I'm okay
are you sure okay well let's get that
dolly good then
yeah that was whatever he said stop
looking at me I can't I can't throw them
away like that like this I'll play then
that's my jam that is my jam man this
game is [ __ ] awesome are you okay man
he's okay what just happened
all right let's then play the actual
game sorry about that
all right so how do we sneak into the
console 8 without [ __ ] a bird without
being seen
hi well you do look a little tiny don't
you all right here we go
but I sex you want high man gone silly I
don't I'm afraid you don't have
appointment well how do you know even
without me saying anything oh it's going
inside me
oh that is good yeah good typesetter
fine of course he got fired anyone use
the comic sense nut and ironically
should be fired all right
twelve is lunch time communists plotting
vodka and biscuits potato sack race
pretty sure that's the scale year for
any any Russian all right what do we
want here exactly I want the potato
whatever oh good heavens look at the
time
[Music]
god damn headphones you ruined my
swagman all right can I go in now
no but I can go out all right so now the
workers are gone I can infiltrate yeah
yeah man I'm like a real spires I'm
freaking like freaking James baby you
need be Tennessee all right let's go
here perfect out yeah that was really
necessary thank you for doing that
top secret okay what else we got Wendy I
owe microscopes on I always wanted to
play a little penis against this
Butthead [ __ ] spiders I'm glad there's
more games with humor in these days well
I'm I'm a freakin dead polling thing
phage complete okay thank you
is there another one here oh I like this
this is some 90s [ __ ] main frickin
potatoes on steroid name what has been
seen all right what we got whoa what the
[ __ ] what is this a tonne of gum bright
cones there's a two thousand six hundred
Hertz whistle inside that's perfect
that's perfect giving it
give me my whistle damn it where is it
yes yes Vega
[Applause]
you like that country yes - I want to
tow there we go
[Applause]
give me what I want come on get to the
point already what whatever is over
three then
[Music]
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] it's me what's up
don't let me think it was Russian the
hell happened to my heart
wait what the [ __ ] I'm only holding
nothing of course oh okay there it is
get a lot of means federal marinated
Neil dumped note whatever the [ __ ] who
cares okay we got it we got what we came
for
now let's get the lady very detailed
game like what the [ __ ] are all these
things I have a picture of Einstein I
can use it as a shield apparently this
is I sign for now what is guys some [ __ ]
take me there you go fire I why did I do
this
caution lower
[ __ ] god that's disgusting why would
they put that on the floor
ah stained dress okay I could someone
could get killed
Clute let's go to clues
well I think we are doing pretty [ __ ]
good so far
yes this makes sense I'm glad we're here
now okay well I guess we're there you go
Hank officiers take one two there you go
and one for me why welcome back
[ __ ] wish to return their
gratitude ah they're on the road for
another job isn't I use our connections
they do have fallen a particularly
valuable officer couldn't [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm gonna get somebody bit just to
restrain this from them at any cost
improvise I know you'll do well Bobby
alright well I have a landline
could you sold mine please because I
have a lot of problem in line huh I did
you just don't want to watch me do you
how did only these shoes get like that
what his shoes are just bare take one
capsule every mission or until a reality
is sufficiently augmented okay starting
mission in three two one go alright
press I really really like this game so
far it is actually really funny live
like me do one more please let me know
it's the sky camera today I see breath
in the next one say awesome
love you bro
[Music]
that's the man welcome back to the man
with pain oh I changed some here
[Music]